hey
at a staging area in the central
highlands near placo
a ground control officer coordinates the
loading
of uh-1d helicopters as units of the
first cavalry division prepare to jump
off
on a search and destroy mission against
the vietcong
the assault choppers lift the air
cavalrymen to landing zones kim
and amy some 70 kilometers northwest of
pleiku
and about 100 meters from the cambodian
border
it is 11 april and the first phase of
operation mosby is beginning
at landing zone kim the immediate
mission of the first wave of troops is
to secure the area for subsequent
sorties
while a perimeter defense is being set
up mortar crews lay their weapons
a smoke grenade is used to signal the
second wave of cavalrymen
that landing zone kim has been secured
and that it is safe to land
the units have drawn no enemy fire and
as the troops hit the ground they move
rapidly to the perimeter of the lz
leaving the center free for helicopter
traffic
these troops will hold the lz for the
next few days
so that other units probing the jungles
around it will have a secure base upon
which to rely for quick support
the overall mission of this battalion
sized operation
is to set up ambushes near the cambodian
border
and to disrupt the suspected bc buildup
of men and materiel in the area
the patrols however were routine other
than the difficult terrain
one of the greatest challenges was to
locate an adequate supply of usable
water
there was no contact with the enemy by
the elements film
and after three days of fruitless probes
the units gave up the search and pulled
back to the doc hodri river
where they began clearing a sandbar for
a three ship landing zone
as the hues touch down the cavalrymen
rush aboard
and will soon be making their second
assault landing within four days
from this pickup point in quantum
province the units are evacuated to
landing zone
joan which they will secure to support
battalion forward operations in the new
area
as the first phase of operation mosby
nears its end
there has been little contact with the
enemy but a considerable amount of dc
equipment and ammunition was captured
after the new lc is secure the units are
resupplied before continuing their
patrols
several days later on 21 april other
units of the first cavalry division move
out of their base camp at on k
to begin the second phase of operation
mosby
this part of the campaign is directed
against an area in placo province
some 25 kilometers northeast of the town
of plaku
in a region where u.s forces have never
before operated
after landing zones are secured chinook
helicopters begin shuttling in
rations ammunition and other equipment
to keep the using units resupplied
at one of the forward lz's artillery
crews quickly lay
their lightweight m-102 howitzers and
begin
firing a mission in support of an
infantry unit that is pushing 2 000
meters to the north
meanwhile the commander of the
brigade-sized force discusses the
situation with subordinate commanders
and his s2
on the following day 22 april a captured
dc
suspect is brought to a forward cp the
prisoner is fed and then turned over to
a vietnamese intelligence officer
for interrogation after detailed
questioning
the captive points out on a map an area
where viet cong might be holed up
the suspect is bound and plans are made
for an attack against the suspected d.c
stronghold with the bound prisoner
in tow a company moves out to
investigate the information
early in the march a grass hut
containing about 1 000 pounds of rice is
located
but there is no sign of the viet cong
the hut is burned to the ground
and the company continues its search of
the area
soon after the company comes upon a
village that appears to be abandoned
the unit holds up at the edge of the
jungle while the co
deploys his platoons around the cluster
of patched huts
houses are far from deserted and all the
villagers
are soon assembled for questioning
although the inhabitants deny any
involvement with the vc
there is disconcerting evidence to the
contrary
a clump of bamboo spikes is found such
as those used by the vc
for pungi spakes also there is a
suspicious number
of able-bodied adult males present after
much questioning through an interpreter
with negative results
the suspected guerrillas are called out
and then marched away
they will be airlifted to a battalion cp
for interrogation
by a vietnamese intelligence officer
then the company leaves the village to
continue its search of the area
at a battalion cp the following day 24
april
the commander of the units participating
in phase two of operation mosby
arrives for a report on latest
developments
this extensive four-day search of an
area 20 by 30 kilometers square
has produced no significant contact with
the enemies
during the second week of april an 0-1
flies over song bay
in quat long province dropping surrender
leaflets
here 120 kilometers northeast of saigon
operation denver is being launched by
the 173rd airborne brigade
on the ground troops sweep through a
rubber plantation on the outskirts of
song bay
snipers fire at the airborne troopers
and a firefight begins
then as suddenly as it began the enemy
firing ceases
and the vietcong break off the men of
the 173rd continue moving up
while medics treat some of the light
casualties sustained during the brief
contact
as the americans come up on the village
there is no sign of life
the vietcong have withdrawn and for now
the fighting is over
at brigade forward general harold k
johnson visits with brigadier general
paul k
smith commanding general of the 173rd
and meets members of general smith's
staff
during his visit the army chief of staff
attends an operational briefing
afterwards as he always does general
johnson talks with the troops
offering praise and encouragement then
he thanks the commanders and continues
his tour of vietnam
this boat is a part of a 12-man river
patrol being conducted on 23 april
by an american advisor and a regional
force unit stationed at huang yuan
some 20 kilometers southeast of saigon
the destination of the patrol is a new
outpost some five kilometers
down the talk on jia river at its
juncture with the long taw river
defensive positions are checked and ways
of improving them are discussed by the
american advisor
and his vietnamese counterpart at the
outpost
then the patrol begins its return to
kuang yuan the same afternoon
the outpost provides security for the
main shipping channel on the long town
which emerges near the mouth of the
saigon river
at benoit on 11 april helicopters of an
aviation battalion are being prepared
for the day's mission the machine gun
ammo track is checked out and the belt
threaded for action
the battalion is supporting vietnamese
special forces
in a move to set up a permanent civilian
irregular defense group camp near song
bay
this operation marks the first use in
vietnam
of the xm31 experimental armament system
with two mounted twenty millimeter
cannon
the copters take off on operation exodus
their mission is to prepare a landing
zone in the area of song bay for an
assault
the aerial 20 millimeter cannon fire
bursts of high explosive
incendiary ammunition
as the time for landing the men
approaches rocket-equipped helicopters
opened fire
together with the first battle
appearance of the 20 millimeter cannon
they subject the enemy to a blanket of
fire
on 16 april the usns general john pope
dropped anchor off the harbor of pinyon
with more than 3 500 combat-ready korean
troops on board
the landing craft are soon filled with
assigned boat teams
and the lcu's head for shore the rock
troops which arrived after a six-day
trip from busan
are part of the 26 regimental combat
team they will be attached to the rock
tiger division
which has been serving in vietnam since
october 1965.
on hand to greet the troops our major
general stanley r
larson commander of field force vietnam
one
and major general shame young shin
commander of the rock tiger division
the arrival of the 26th brings to
approximately 25
000 the number of koreans assigned to
south vietnam
in addition to the tiger division this
includes some 2500 rock engineers
and the korean marine blue dragon
the troops were still debarking admiral
usg
sharp commander-in-chief pacific and
general william c
westmoreland commander of u.s forces
vietnam arrived to welcome them
also present to greet the 26th commanded
by colonel juan sikh park
is the korean ambassador to south
vietnam mr shin sanchos
the rock units will undergo five weeks
of training nearby
and will then move to their area of
responsibility
ban khan valley some 20 kilometers
northwest of quinyan
on 21 april in washington dc the white
house rose garden
is the setting for a posthumous
presentation of the nation's highest
award for heroism
the medal of honor to pfc milton e olive
iii
relatives and family friends attend
the president states that pfc olive had
made the hardest decision any man can
make
to put others first and himself last
six months ago the 19 year old soldier
from chicago was with his platoon
on a jungle trail near pukuang vietnam
when a viet cong grenade landed in their
midst pfc olive threw himself
over the live grenade and saved the
lives of his fellow servicemen
his father receives the medal and
citation from president johnson
near placo in april a master control
station is being built for the deca
navigational system
deca is a highly stable all-weather
radio position fixing service
which provides aircraft physician
information from a set of widely spaced
radio transmitting stations
when the subsidiary slave stations are
constructed
this system will cover the central part
of vietnam from the 17th parallel down
to dallas
technical personnel are helping to
install the new system
the first deca system became operational
in the southern part of vietnam in
january 1963
with stations located at consonaut bang
tao
and three smaller towns it has assisted
greatly in combat assault missions
resupply of units aircraft recovery
medevac and other missions
here two of the technicians prepare a
rough draft of a flight map
at consonant air base after studying the
rough map
they plot topography detail on the
original flight map
which later will be made into printing
plates
a technician reproduces copies of the
flight log
chart which will be inserted into a
display mechanism mounted on the console
of the aircraft
information is furnished to the aircraft
up to a distance of several hundred
kilometers
this information is either used to
position a map
or is shown directly on a chart in
pictorial form
with navigational accuracy of
approximately 500 meters
it can help a pilot to find a specific
location
in unidentifiable terrain
here the technical maintenance crews
installed the deca system
into two uh-1b helicopters on the flight
line
into the console the technician installs
the three
phase reading meters which provide the
basic information to the operator
tech reps work on the installation of
the receiver antenna under the
helicopter
the flight chart keys which program the
computer chart scale
go into the console the display holds 20
feet of chart
and provides the pictorial presentation
to give the operator a constant track of
his roof
then the display with its map is mounted
in the cockpit
the newly installed equipment is
explained to the crew chief
he has shown the computer in its storage
compartment and the console with a chart
display and keys
the huey now makes a test flight
the moving flight log chart with its
needle marks the helicopter's course
this system will help future operations
by providing accurate air lifts
and fire delivery from gunships
this radio relay installation situated
at vung tau
overlooking the mouth of the saigon
river is part of a steadily expanding
network of radio stations
being constructed in south vietnam
the chain of stations called the
integrated wide band communications
system
is operated by the united states army
strategic communications command
and now covers most of southeast asia
construction of new terminals such as
this bung tau
project is going forward at a rapid pace
to provide improved service
for constantly increasing transmission
requirements
farther north along the coast of south
vietnam at
natron another tropospheric scatter site
is undergoing development
like most it is operated from a van
a new warehouse will provide storage for
the many items required to service this
terminal
as part of the southeast asia network
these vietnam installations will handle
voice
data and message transmission inland at
play coup
385 kilometers north of saigon the new
iwcs radio terminal
is installing large fuel storage tanks
the tanks will provide efficient fuel
service
for the station's power generators
still another troposcatter site is
located at da nang
160 kilometers southeast of the border
between north and south vietnam here
antenna foundations and generator sheds
are being built
van controls are in
the terminal at fulam another site on
the central coastal plain
has been in operation for some time
the base is well advanced and mps stand
guard at the entrance screening all
vehicles
to make sure no bombs or infiltrators
are hidden beneath entering vehicles
they are checked with this mirror device
here at fulam construction of new
facilities continues
though still under construction these
iwcs stations are already part
of the worldwide stratcom network
at panmunjom korea on 23 april
major general joseph oh butcher u.s
marine corps
arrives at the military armistice
commission meeting for his first
session as senior representative of the
united nations command
major general park chung cook of north
korea
makes a statement discrediting all
previous un members
and asking for general butcher's
cooperation then u.n members listen to
accusations of armistice violations
general butcher and other un
representatives listen to the familiar
charges
when it is his turn to address the
meeting general butcher replies by
showing a north korean propaganda film
that depicts the introduction of modern
russian equipment
to north korea
people outside the building crowd the
windows in an attempt to see
at the conclusion of the film north
korea moves to adjourn
general butcher after listening calls
for integrity in the commission
then accepts adjournment and the members
of the commission depart
they will now continue with research and
evaluation
of information in preparation for the
next meeting
business camp ramble near santo domingo
base for units of the 82nd airborne
division
which is part of the ready force of the
iaps
units of the military police are
inspected and receive their patrol
orders before they
move out on their daily mission
in april 14 patrols range daily
throughout the city
including the area now known as the
rebel sector
the inter-american police force is
composed of eight
thousand troops from six countries
including one thousand soldiers and
marines from brazil
and men from nicaragua paraguay honduras
costa rica and the united states
the patrols are accompanied by dominican
national police
mp vehicles guide convoys for 16 hours
daily
along the msr the main supply route
which crosses the center of santo
domingo
the military police were brought in to
help the civilian population
this sergeant tells about his present
duty
i find the big difference in pulling
duty here rather than any place else
is that more than law enforcement we
have a large security
problem and mission probably the biggest
job of the military police in the
dominican republic
requires the most thought planning and
people
is the security of the u.s forces here
u.s forces installations and vip
security
confusing political slogans for the june
1st election
seem to be on every wall bollager is the
conservative candidate
the liberal's nomination is former
president bush
one voter writes go home yankee and take
me with you
u.s army engineers and a pipeline unit
are making rapid progress on the pol
tank farm under construction near
satahip thailand
three of the five storage tanks planned
for the farm
had been completed and much related work
accomplished when these scenes were
filmed on 25 april
after the grading and leveling
operations are finished the entire area
will be blacktop
here a weld is being made on a pipe that
will be used later in a feeder line
meanwhile other engineers and a tie
laborer
install a t-joint in the pipeline to the
first completed storage tank
elsewhere personnel are joining pipes
from the storage tanks to the filter
separators
all underground pipes connecting the
storage tanks have been laid previously
and the filter separator is installed
each of the bolted steel storage tanks
will hold ten thousand barrels of
aircraft fuel
the fourth tank has been started and the
base constructed for the fifth
completion is scheduled for 25 june some
four months after work began
thailand 144 kilometers north of bangkok
the provincial hospital is cooperating
with the sito general medical research
lab of bangkok
in the study of the various forms of
malaria
in a hospital a cage of mosquitoes is
fed the blood of a malaria patient
for the transfer of the disease to given
malaria studies comprise a large
percentage of seto's medical research
long-term investigations are made
primarily by the hospital staff
most malaria research involves the use
of non-human hosts
human malaria has been successfully
transmitted to gibbons
by injections and by mosquitoes
at the feto laboratory in bangkok
specimens are received for evaluation
from all parts of thailand
these specimens are primarily body
fluids
such as blood urine and spinal fluid
the technician here injects fluid into
test bios
as the entomology lab conducts a
precipitant test
of mosquito blood meals
a great deal of field work is required
to collect specimens and samples of
diseases and virus throughout thailand
medical teams are constantly at work in
the field
forwarding specimens to the research lab
in bangkok
for evaluation and cataloging
the united states has been working with
thailand in medical research for over
five years
the us component of the lab is a special
activity of walter reed army institute
of research
u.s army medical research and
development command
research collaboration is also performed
with the thai ministry of public health
the school of tropical medicine and the
ministries of agriculture
and interior
in the automatic blood analyzer
specimens are drawn through the tube
system
and the results scribed on the recording
unit
an american technician takes the
recorded data of the test
and by means of an overlay chart reads
the results
malaria affects more people in thailand
than any other disease
in the cooperative research project the
problem of disease resistance to drugs
is being investigated
seven of nine scientific departments
here are involved in the study of
malaria
the results of this research are of
great importance in both peace and war
in the mountains near la paz bolivia the
national department of criminal
investigation
operates the valley of hope it is
literally that for some 40 bolivian boys
who were picked up by the police for
minor offenses
such as stealing food bolivian
detectives founded the home
rather than see these boys of 8 to 18
sent to jail
begun some five months ago this project
immediately drew the interest of the us
army mission as a worthwhile off-duty
project
u.s military personnel have also
established a voluntary aid fund
in addition to personal participation
they supply some needed materials in
this case
cement
an early us gift was unbleached muslin
the boys soon converted this to straw
and weed-filled mattresses
a number of skills are learned here
carpentry
and stone carving are two ways of
directing energy into constructive
channels
there are garden plots where the boys on
their own raise a variety of basic
vegetables
the boys provide whatever they can with
their own efforts
as their water supply is open to
contamination
an officer of the us army engineers
gives professional advice
for self-help improvement an underground
water pipe with cemented joints is the
result
the bolivian boys town is housed in an
old hacienda
which the boys are restoring the home
operates on 100
a month made up of monthly donations by
bolivian detectives
plus off-duty help from the u.s mission
the boys sleep in an abandoned railway
station
school is not neglected classes are held
at the hacienda
representatives of other schools are
invited to visit and study the project
in the hope that this will encourage
donations of much needed books and
supplies
some of the cement supplied by usarmus
donations
is used to improve the swimming pool
some will be used to repair the small
chapel housing the statue of the patron
saint of wayward children
members of the u.s mission have the
satisfaction of time well spent
in helping the bolivian police give
these young people a better start in
life
high atop mount gulielmo in northern
italy a badly deteriorated refuge is
being rebuilt through the combined
efforts of u.s army personnel
and the local populace for many years
the residents of nearby gardoni
valtrophia
a village nestled in the foothills of
the alps have wanted to rebuild the
monument to the redeemer
but faced the almost impossible task of
hauling the materials on their backs
up to the six thousand foot pinnacle
the southern european task force
responded to a request for assistance
by furnishing two ch-34 helicopters
for an airlift of construction materials
from the pickup point to the mountaintop
the airlift began on 21 april and was
scheduled to continue for about two
weeks
an estimated 440 flights will be needed
to transport the 400 tons of materials
as the choctaws reach the summit
youngsters of the village delight in the
strange noisy aircraft
while their fathers retrieve and store
the sand gravel and lumber
meanwhile back in the valley a new cross
for the monument is readied for sling
lift to the summit
senator lidovico montini brother of pope
paul
and the commander of ctaf major general
george w
power discussed the project the
villagers under the leadership of pope
paul's father
built the monument in 1902 ctas
assistance in this project
was hailed by local publications as an
example of its
by now well-known usual and generous
spirit of cooperation
you